just hot for no reason
it's like using battery acid
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Florence Pugh
hello she's an Academy Award nominated
actor with a long and growing list of
acclaimed performances from Lady Macbeth
the Black Widow Little Women in
mid-summer and many more you can also
catch your starting alongside Morgan
Freeman in her latest film a good person
which is set to release in theaters
worldwide March 24th Florence Pugh
welcome to the show
I know that face I know that face I'm
glad that it's cold in here though we
keep the air condition on Full Tilt here
at hot ones I see as a fan of your
cooking with flow series that you're
always working with spice in the kitchen
what's going through your head as you
prepare to take on the hot ones
um I'm not okay I'm I'm not terrified
about the middle ones I'm I'm terrified
about the other ones just from seeing
you all the guests like but probably
thought and um need to walk around the
room but uh yeah I like using a bit of
spice I like I like um intense flavors
so I think I'm gonna be marginally okay
but I've got all of my stuff in case
we'll just see how it goes yeah okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I already did the thing that I said I
wasn't gonna do
okay so I have a plan the plan was I've
seen lots of these interviews and
everybody makes the one mistake which is
they pick it up with both hands and then
later on they go like that or that and
then they die
but I'm okay I'm gonna lick this one
okay so that this one's clean there you
go
do that
everyone ready ready okay
that's nice I like that
[Music]
any day every day yamo
put that on the bottle put that yeah any
day everywhere yummo
so in a good person you play the role of
Allison a character whose life comes
completely undone in the wake of a
tragic car crash and despite the weight
of the material there actually are some
funny scenes in the film like when your
character is inspired to cut off her
hair after watching a beauty influencer
on YouTube yeah what do you see as the
value of humor or levity in a story as
dark as this one I think that's just how
we deal with things I think is people as
humans we go through some of the darkest
and the saddest parts of our life
um constantly next to friends and family
bringing humor bringing laughter weirdly
enough even though those times are
totally terrifying and completely
heartbreaking people band together and
they make it possible to get through and
it's through having friends that make
you laugh it's through having siblings
that uh you know wrestle you or tickle
you it's the same thing it's it's you
you need you need lightness in times of
darkness and I think that's something
that Zach is really good at doing
[Music]
sizing it up that's lovely I'd have that
on many things I'd even put that in a
dressing
I like that idea or even on a pizza like
with some goats cheese I can see and
some olives or maybe some red eyes sorry
I want that one that's gonna be in my
kitchen oh shoot
so I'm fascinated by the art of eating
on camera what were Sebastian Leo's
notes for your recurring scenes and the
wonder where you're just pounding
Play-Doh play a pretty Grim looking
Irish food well that was the point it
was supposed to look gnarly and it was
supposed to look uh like there was no
nutritional value in it whatsoever
um and so we actually it was actually
kind of really tasty food it was this
vegan food prep company that would put
black dye and green dye and gray dye
into all the foods and it was so tasty
I'd be eating like these bowls of gray
food and at the end of the day there'd
be so much of it that I would take it
home and put it in the fridge and so
when people would come around the house
like why'd you have gray food in
tupperware so no no just try it's really
delicious
I don't know his Direction was just like
this is your thinking time this is like
you Mission Food it's horrible you need
it
and I love those scenes I think eating
on camera is so cool especially when you
actually get to eat and swallow and
because most of the time when you're
shooting things they're all like don't
eat it don't touch it you know this is
gonna be a long day make sure you just
nibble and it's one of my biggest pet
peeves when you watch a scene and
someone's just like moving the food
around the plate and doesn't actually
eat it well on that topic is there any
movie Magic that goes into like a scene
in Hawkeye 10 minutes long and your
character is just smothering mac and
cheese and hot sauce no that was that
just a spicy food that was pretty much
my idea to essentially have a dream day
at work and eat mac and cheese all day
long and then they had Sriracha on the
table as a prop and I was like is this
real the props guys yeah it's real it's
like right and so every single take I'm
just shoveling in mouthfuls of sriracha
I had a fantastic day it was great they
came and they asked my lunch order I
said are you kidding I've been eating
bowls and like pots of mac and cheese
all morning well I'm sure that it served
you well for today's interview are you
ready to move on
so this is the donuts cadejo here in the
three spot
okay I like that's a very intimidating
label is that a rabbit bunny
[Music]
okay you've already done it oh [__]
dancing on it that seems like a good
sign
there it is Yep this is the first kind
of like step that we do yeah it's it's
acidy I'm feeling notes of it's not as
salty as the others
it's definitely coming at you with the
spice at the back of the throat back of
the throat it's sticking to the tongue
quite a bit yeah
well that'll be the cumulative effect
here as we go you know I think that
would be good with some meat maybe or
maybe even a bit of fish what about some
prawns oh well I can't wait over the
wedge of lime on the side you just
squeeze that with some prawns I'd love
that
so you've described yourself as a Chatty
Cathy on set you can go from you know
filming an intense scene one moment and
then talking it up with the cast and
crew to see everything about how a movie
gets made yeah do you have a standout I
never knew that's how it works moment
from your film career so far
always I guess you're Bamboozled by this
world it's like strange things so many
people behind a camera there's a boom
like right here
and I think like you're just so amazed
by all of these new terms and these new
words and like oh I'm gonna go ten one
you're like what's ten one it's a wee
why don't you just say you're going for
a wee that doesn't make any sense but
they're all these new terms and then I
think on every single job I'm relaxing a
bit more and understanding it a bit more
and so I now have like all this time to
go up to these incredible crew members
and be like how does that work or when
you take apart the camera like this what
is it you're looking for I think it's so
important and crucial to be excited
about the thing that we're making and
especially if you're shooting in digital
and then shooting another film in film
like I've had the privilege of shooting
on film twice that's a whole different
world for example if the camera breaks
for a second or if it if if the shutter
doesn't come down or the film doesn't go
through
like a camera surgeon will walk on set
with a little surgical bag almost like
the doctor like someone just said hey
can the doctor come up please virus
sprained her ankle the camera surgeon
will come up and like open his bag and
be like
you eat it and it's just insane they
take it apart and they're fixing this
camera and it's just I I find that stuff
so fascinating
so yeah it's completely different and
then someone comes in with all the film
and it's this whole big thing to shimmy
this piece of film into this camera and
then it's someone's job to run away with
the old one and if he breaks it he's
[__] because that's a whole film gone
because of him it's some it's nuts it's
amazing
[Music]
see I like this packaging this is like
I'm on a holiday yeah yeah I'm by the PO
oh it's hot ones yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I didn't even mean to pick it up I
guess I work it now you're hired yeah
okay
oh sorry just outside of this like okay
so imagine that working on Shakespeare
with classically trained actors has a
different tenor than your average film
set do you recall what struck you the
most when running rehearsals for the
2016 adaptation of King Lear that you
did alongside Anthony Hopkins and Emma
Thompson so that was I was very very
nervous when I um was shooting that
partly because I hadn't um oh apparently
my first bit of upper lip sweat
that's a thing cool okay it's working
um
I had never done theater before I
definitely felt like oh I need to put my
big girl pants on and so when we went to
rehearsals
I just sat in this room with all these
great theater Legends and Shakespeare
Legends and Anthony Hopkins was so
excited and Hyper that it was all coming
together and I think he'd been wanting
to do this for a really long time so he
knew the play off by heart just seeing
someone like that at that age with that
Talent just to be just as kind of
excited and nervous as me was really
cool and then also with that you've just
got to know your [__] if you're being
given this opportunity and you've got
the Limelight and you've got the
microphone then know what to do with it
because this is your shot
I like that packaging that doesn't look
so scary
[Music]
you just did a bad thing but I do you
just rubbed your hands together you know
what it's that I can't shake that
yeah but now you're gonna touch your
face no no not at this point
I know
but thank you for looking out that's
okay I just saw this pink there's red
thumbs I was like uh oh no yeah I know I
know I react the same way I think from
this point on I'm Gonna Keep one hand up
this one oh no it's this one wait
okay this one because this is the one
for that and then if I need to wipe my
face then I'll go like that that's a
clean hand okay all right I can see it I
can see it all hands up
all right Florence will we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram we're doing a deep
dive on our guests and scramble
interesting pictures that need more
context okay so we'll put the picture up
over here on the moniker you just tell
us the bigger story okay
can you break down the mechanics
for stepping into the flower dress and
then follow up what's the most memorable
Eerie painting that you saw on the walls
of Midsummer said that dress was so
heavy looks like it I was so heavy and
these amazing costume makers and
designers uh spent months weeks making
that and all of those flowers were
individually made they were handmade and
they all have wire in them so every
single one of those flowers then
obviously weighs adds to the weight of
the dress it would take like 15 minutes
or 20 minutes to get in and out of it so
I tried to stay still and so it meant
that on the hot days I'd get [__] hot
and that's why I have the fan
but yeah what was the next bit of your
question uh Eerie painting like Aries
yes there was one in that well there
were many in there but there was one
above the bed that I think I was
sleeping in or Pele was sleeping in
and it was this like splayed body with
this this like she was naked displayed
body with this like very intricately
painted pubic hair and she was like this
and the guy was dancing over and he had
the tiny like tiny tiny little toad
really like that it's tiny and on the
tip it had like delicately drawn juices
coming out of it and it was just like
how is this on a Bed above our head and
unless you look at it that's what you're
seeing and when you go in you're like
wow these are so pretty and then you
just get up close right like that's
horrific what is going on there but they
were all handmade and I you know props
to the design it was absolutely amazing
but yeah there were some [__] up
paintings the devil's in the details in
that one
devils in the details
[Music]
why have they put mushrooms in it
there's only one way mushrooms
fingers crossed are they spicy mushrooms
they're so they're spicy Portobellos in
this one oh because I don't actually
spicy mushrooms
they make them spicy
flowing flow flowing I'm just figuring
out where it goes whoa yeah different
level here
[Music]
that took a while yeah some of them have
that kind of time release weird where it
drops that's yummy you like you like
that you like it though there we go I
like that
what about if that's on some like beans
yeah yeah I'm taking notes over here
yeah I mean it definitely made my lips
wet but that's nice you're writing it
down
well what about that on potatoes
jungle potato with some cheddar and some
sour cream
[Music]
it's a recipe I can put that one down
now here we go
what are the nuts and bolts of shooting
in a scene like the one that you have in
good person where you're serenading a
whole room on the piano like is there an
added pressure to nail a scene like that
and limited takes when you're doing a
musical performance especially when
there's loads of people in the room
because naturally you put yourself in
like a oh my God kind of headspace but
you um you know also what was really
beautiful about that scene was obviously
we had lots of essays that day and we
had lots of day players but we also
invited as many of our friends as
possible
so it did actually feel like a party
environment it was actually a really
really wonderful thing to shoot and
they're in love so yeah
oh I know what's happening you're going
to pass my hand up oh is this one bad
well you went silent and did like some
sort of like yeah like I'm like as a
moment
it's that time in the hot sauce lineup
where it just gets like that
flowing
so this is what it means when it's
really bad you're just gonna do this we
are we're just gonna Vibe our way
through it okay and what a sauce to do
it on it's called dreams of calypso wow
I wish
oh I'm not gonna look like that am I
often guys there's this beautiful
mermaid with purple hair and a wonderful
bikini and a tail I'm not gonna look
like that I'm gonna be swimming in my
own sweat I'm sure
stand up okay where are we going ready
I'm ready wait I'm gonna go the nice
side okay
[Music]
sorry that's a bit of asthma for you
oh
yeah
it's growing I like it though kind of an
experience I'm so surprised by how long
it oh come and takes
I'm trying
to do a mid-summer
yeah
[Laughter]
okay I'm going for the fun of the lip
why yep yep
[Music]
oh
do you have a favorite historic Pub in
Oxford I heard it's not uncommon there
we go oh my God it's amazing and if you
ever that come tough Tavern is old it's
legendary all the doors are like yay
high because people were really short
back then and it's like something in
Harry Potter I mean it's obviously
Oxford is where a lot of Harry Potter
yeah
all of the amazing writers all wrote
there and they have all of their all of
the list of people that worked there and
not worked in the pub but went and wrote
there it is like something from Harry
Potter like you're going down this
Alleyway and then something will turn
the corner and everybody's partying with
witch capes and brooms and stuff it's
this tiny little like
tuft of a building that has these short
low bars and amazing beers and ciders
and it's such an experience I love it
well I'm sold yeah are you coming I'm
coming you're gonna bring all your
sources if I can get through customs
yeah with oil sources yeah yeah we'll
see how it goes all right and this next
one actually might be a problem Oh this
is the bomb Beyond Insanity yeah you
wouldn't be able to take that out yeah
are you gonna do a dance or is it not
that kind of one oh no
no yeah you just did a
I did I'm churning I'm sure
okay ready how much do we do to oh
you're already in bye game over that's
plenty right there but I know I've done
it was that too much it's too late now
it's gonna happen
I I think I went like that yeah
now you can't do the left hand it's it's
compromised
no I know I know
just hot for no reason
it's like eating battery acid
yeah actually literally
I know I know I know
so through your cooking with flow series
you know it shows off your cooking Bona
fides which really shouldn't come as a
surprise doesn't know that you've worked
in and around hospitals I know I know
without thinking about it too hard what
are four cheeses that in an
uncompromised way have to be on the
cheese board of your dreams
there it goes wow
it wasn't dramatic thanks
yeah I found the light and everything
[Music]
so nothing fun about that
yeah I think it would have to be
like a
a goat's cheese maybe
I don't know what gouda hmm
or maybe like a
[Music]
that is really crunchy yeah
and not too sharp
I just can't believe that when I breathe
it makes it hotter that's so unfair
right right right like I breathe it
should make it better
and I don't like how they grow you know
what I mean like I don't like how you
think you're out of place and then it
just kind of keeps getting it's like a
deceitful manipulative person it's like
oh I'm nice actually no he was never
nice no no immediately you should have
known he was like
lots of red flags he was like nasty to
taste with at the beginning he didn't
take me on a date he wasn't polite
he didn't open the car door nor did he
give me his umbrella
and then just like
keeps on being mean yeah right doesn't
stop and why am I still with him
[Music]
I've learned and that is probably the
best thing that I can tell anyone who's
gonna do the show
to breathe the lick your lips
I'm gonna use one hand
ready yeah
see not like the bomb right
right
it's not pleasant I'm sweating from my
eyebrows my eyebrows are sweating
oh my God I'm actually sweating from my
eyebrows that's sweat from my eyebrow
that's the bomb
wow that's like perfectly imprinted yeah
it's like a
study it's like a hand print you know
it's like very unique to your brush and
then that's my mustache
[Music]
okay
do you remember why you decided to play
mother Mary with a thick North English
accent or first ever School play because
my grandparents are from Grimm's beam
and my grandparents um had kind of like
this sometimes soft sometimes
not uh Yorkshire accent and I would
always take the piss out of my granddad
and I'd always be doing this accent and
um he would like
sometimes bust my granny around and so
I'd be like oh Puck get me a cup of tea
I'd be like taking the biz out of him
and so when I got Mary
aged six
I was like well gotta make her
interesting you know got to set me apart
from all the other Mary's what if they
come around and
oh that's not
[Music]
up in the top it's fresh people
okay that's a reasonable amount yeah
yeah but you can never hang on let me
show you yeah be careful though that
that that's so good that yeah which it's
[__] hot isn't it it is hot
I just heard someone go oh
yeah that's good that's
that's okay okay
all right Florence see you on the other
side see on the other side
and while you slow marinating that all
right Florence I just want to remind you
that the wings of death they're behind
us they're an afterthought and I think
to close things out we should meet you
halfway the simple foundational pleasure
that you have in life with brewing a
perfect cup of tea so here it is a full
Mison plus oh my goodness I'm gone more
hot things
so if you could just take us through
step by step
it's time
what we're gonna do is what kind of tea
bags are these we actually we got your
uh Yorkshire Yorkshire gold we know that
that's your bag this is my Grandad
Stan's favorite this is my dad's
favorite is my brother's favorite and
didn't you get your own I should get oh
I did I go my own they made such a flex
yeah I did slightly too much water
because you need to leave room for milk
so we're gonna pour like this
lovely tea set
man
I'm gonna put that on the side for you
and that other side for me
sauce and
I'll take that one yeah you're gonna
have this oh no I have a freshie okay
you have this one and then we're gonna
pour it I like having the tea bags still
in some people don't like having the tea
bags and if online people are gonna be
like ah she's crazy or like oh my God
that's the only way you should do it but
genuinely it is so divisive it's best
not to talk about it when you make
friends with someone because it actually
could be like right the defining thing
foreign
I'm Gonna Keep It In as I just told you
because I like it the reason why I like
it is because
it's interesting
is because
um you get to kind of make it into a bit
of a thicker brew and I like that
and then we serve tea thank you Florence
it's okay
are you ready I'm ready this is gonna be
far more enjoyable than the hot sauce
well at least it's a bomb but it might
be really bloody hot though this is
probably the problem Oh get your
digestive yep don't carve it in hold it
there
bring it out
[Music]
um
how nice is
it's yeah it's kind of it starts out
nice it's kind of hard
I will have a sip though
do you think that's dangerous only one
way to find out
thumbs up thumbs up
Bottoms Up
oh
that was the worst idea why did we do
that why did you bring that out that is
so hot
but
but it wasn't too delicious cup of tea
and look at you Florence dude taking on
the wings of death yeah living to tell
the tale have a screening red carpet
event later I'm gonna be sweating
everything my makeup's not gonna stand
my face but in the meantime there's
nothing left to do but roll out this red
carpet for you okay this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life I
have going on a burnt tongue a great
session with all these hot sauces
I would so love it if you went to go and
watch a good person it's funny it's sad
um I I hope it affects you and please
please let us know what you think
because it means and matters a lot to us
so enjoy
don't
eat them
thank you can I have beer now yeah yeah
you can have a beer
you've earned it that's happening in my
stomach like I can I can feel it yeah
becoming one kind of yes wow I'm like
sweating but you did so good you did so
good mind your your hands are hands very
spicy
cheers cheers
whoa
hot ones fans breaking news the three in
one boneless bites challenge is back for
a limited time you can put your taste
buds to the test against some of our
most iconic flavors the classic Los
Calientes and the peak of heat Apollo
but don't fret hot ones fans even when
the three in one challenge leaves the
freezer aisle you can still pick up your
favorite flavor of hot ones boneless
bites visit
hotoneschallenge.com for more
information on products and to find a
store near you because it's time to
bring the Heat home